and when you tune into nbc for sunday
night football one of the guys that
you'll see out on the field wearing the
gold helmet is george kittle one of the
best tight ends right now if not the
very best tight ends in the national
football league george welcome back how
are you
um excellent thanks for having me what's
your reaction when you find out
yesterday that the 49ers gonna be
playing that that return match against
the seahawks in prime time on nbc with
everyone watching
uh pretty excited i missed the last one
so excited to get another shot these
guys and especially it's in seattle i
don't think we've won there for a long
time it'll be a good challenge for the
team and we're just really looking
forward to it you got the playoffs
starting after that how important is it
to your team given that you didn't have
a buy since week four to get that week
off before you have to play a single
elimination game
yeah i was pretty early
um definitely been playing a lot of
football since then so that would uh be
very helpful for our team just give guys
a week off get the bodies back um be
very helpful you know that's our goal
and we're gonna do everything we can to
win this game you know the the seahawks
are very banged up especially at running
back there's some chatter that marshawn
lynch could end up back with the
seahawks is that one of those things you
look at and say boy this is kind of i
know you don't play defense but is this
kind of intriguing the idea to see
marshawn lynch back on the field or are
you just fine fine without marshawn
lynch coming out of retirement
that'd be awesome i love watching him
play so um i know i mean whatever he i
mean he brings a lot to the table so
he'd be an unreal challenge but um you
know i'm just i'll let that play out but
i'm a fan of it so i i would love to see
that i know one of the things rodney
harrison brings up every time of year as
the playoffs start the intensity of the
postseason how the game changes how the
hitting changes how everything about it
changes and the 49ers collectively don't
have a lot of playoff experience how
much are you already leaning on the guys
who have been there and done that for
for just pointers and advice on what to
expect when the playoffs roll around
um no a little bit here and there but
you know we're still you know just
focused on the regular season but this
is definitely going to be like a playoff
game we know that um the last saturday
night was definitely a playoff game in
our opinion and so we're just gonna you
know just keep playing our football our
brand of football which is physical
moving the ball and you know trying to
you know get our run down run game down
your throats and so we're just going to
keep doing that and that saturday night
game was a classic obviously the rams
were knocked out with the loss tied late
that drive with two third and 16s that
get converted i don't think i've ever
seen that happen before when you're
lining up for the second third and 16
are you thinking there's no way in hell
we're going to do this again
oh i know the play call i was like hey
well this is either going to be a
complete big shot or i don't know what's
going to happen and i look like i was
looking at jimmy you know i was in
protection released to the flat
um and i look he i just see him launch
and i was like oh wow uh i looked
downfield and manual is wide open so
that was pretty awesome and
it just kind of worked i guess
how how has it been for you to go
through this process of becoming a star
player a guy that opposing teams are
focusing on shutting down with double
teams and extra resources how has that
affected you how has that changed your
game
um i mean really hasn't i just go out
there and i just play football um
whether there's one or two guys on me uh
it doesn't really matter i just do
whatever i can to get open you know
coach shanahan schemes plays for me to
get one-on-ones and i just have to take
advantage of those situations which i've
done a pretty good job of this year and
coach shanahan do you know we do some
creative stuff back there which allows
me to get open it's pretty fun and uh
you know i just go out there and i play
football when you pull off a win like
the one that we saw on saturday night
and and the way that you did it with
those two third and teams how much
confidence does that give to the team
heading into the biggest game of the
regular season
uh a lot um you know definitely the way
that it get that game ended um
you know i i think a lot of people
thought i was going to ot for sure but
the fact that you know jimmy could stay
in the pocket and deliver two thirds and
sixteenths back to back on two beautiful
passes um
just says a lot about our team and says
a lot about jimmy g and how he can
deliver and how he leads this team and
we're just going to keep carrying that
momentum into this game uh coming up
center sunday night obviously had the
season derailed last year in week three
with his knee injury a lot of questions
about him going into the season it seems
like he's answered most of those what
have you seen from him this year as he's
developed and grown and made some big
throws in big spots just consistency uh
i mean even back in otas he makes the
same passes he's the same guy every
single day nothing ever gets to him
whether you know it's an interception
and complete pass
a bad check it does nothing really
affects him and he just comes back the
next play and he's dialed and ready to
go and you know that's what i love about
jimmy just the consistency he brings you
know we have we have a really young team
too we have a lot of young guys out
there playing and making big plays and
so with his consistency it just keeps
everyone locked and loaded and everyone
focused and he just keeps delivering the
ball whenever we ask him
george you mentioned that you had missed
the first game against the seahawks you
had the ankle and the knee injury and i
remember watching that thursday night
game against the cardinals and you took
that hit to the knee and i thought oh
crap
this is not good and then you're back on
the field how in the hell were you able
to keep going for the rest of that game
or at least most of the rest of the game
after you had that knee injury
um
i really got athletic trainers got a
nice tape job on the knee uh stabilize
it a little bit and just let me play um
you know it's football stuff happens and
you just gotta you know kind of play
through stuff kyle shanahan praised you
throughout that period of the time that
you were injured as a guy who like if
anybody can play with these injuries
it's george kittle what is it about you
that makes you different from other
players when it comes to that ability
that willingness that drive
determination to find a way to fight
through injury and get on the field and
be as good as you are while injured as
you are when you're not injured
um it's football it's 16 17 weeks and no
one really cares if you're hurt or not
um there's still a game we played every
single sunday and so i just in my eyes
it's just expected of you you know it's
been in my job description i play
football whether you know no matter
what's going on and you know if i can
get on the field i'm going to be on the
field i know you got to get to work
before we let you go panda express is
the sponsor that has made this
appearance available tell us what you
have going on with them
oh uh well you know pan express it's a
thing that i've you know loved for a
long time um honestly i was really
excited when i kind of fell into this
relationship just something i've been
you know i've loved it since i was a
little kid and um panda mondays on
twitter is something that me and some
one of my teammates started a couple
years ago and just kind of you know kept
going and going and going but now i got
a sponsorship with them it's just really
fun you know we talked about the honey
sesame chicken breast which is a
campaign that we're doing um it's
getting towards the end of it but you
know panic express really likes it and i
love it i know it's one of my favorite
dishes and uh it's just one of those
things that it's just personally fun for
me because i connect so well with it and
i've loved it since i was a little kid
um and you know i'm thinking of this
because i know you have a bernie doodle
i've got a bernie doodle and i when i
went into the relationship
my position was
only dog food that's why they make dog
food you don't need to be eating people
food what's your position on whether or
not your dog gets to eat you know the
food off the table or leftovers or
anything other than what goes into the
bowl out of that bag that that giant
heavy bag of of this stuff that no that
not that no dog or human should eat
uh you know depending on what it is i
definitely like sharing my dog um you
know just saying the honey sesame
chicken breast is uh completely organic
so that's something i would definitely
share with my dog she does like that
stuff
what is her position on begging does she
like make noise does she just sit
mine just sits she's very smart she just
sits there she just wants to know i'm
here in the event possibly that there
may be a piece that drops on the ground
or you want to give it to me i'm here
but i'm not going to bother you i'm
going to let you eat what does your dog
do
she says sir if i'm sitting at like my
counter she'll have her head on my lap
as i'm eating just staring at me
and she just goes person to person
whoever she knows has the most food she
just moves
she's terrible my dog knows like when we
have family over she knows from history
who to target she knows who's going to
accidentally drop food on the floor
repeatedly so
my dad she stays there the whole meal is
over that's great stuff well george we
gotta let you run you got to get to work
big game coming up on sunday night
congratulations on all your success this
year and all the best for the post
season we look forward to seeing you on
sunday night football and beyond happy
holidays and uh we hope to talk to you
soon hey thank you so much for having me
on it's a blast
all right george thanks man
well of course i don't know you have to
burn a doodle that's awesome oh she's
great she's awesome she's old
she is about a year and a half
oh i just turned two yeah she's great
she is great there she is oh there she
is oh all right all right well one sec
mine is we just shaved mine
check this one out danny come here
oh here
cue set
there you go
oh you know mine got the same thing the
shave shaved off the face looked like a
different dog yeah macy had the same
thing
yeah look at her tail
yep
mine's got the same tail and we're
getting the rest of her body clipped
because they clipped all the matted hair
off of her ears and off of her offer she
mine does the same thing with her paw
too
she had all that stuff here that long
stuff and it was all matted and it was
like where's our dog who's this so
that's good
good stuff everybody
all right hey nice talking to you man
take care
bye
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports